hi
everyone thank you for attending this
session
my name is paula mehta and i'm a product
manager on the cloud ai team
and today i'm going to talk to you about
delivering highly personalized product
recommendations
with recommendations they have later in
this session
we'll also get to hear from our partners
at bigcommerce and cubic
about the success they've had for
rolling out recommendations
to their customers to begin with though
let's acknowledge the metaphorical
elephant in the room
customer shopping behavior has changed
for good
with fewer in-store shopping visits
retailers have had to shore up their
digital storefronts
and explore new ways to meaningfully
engage with their customers
delivering a superior customer
experience has become
even more of a differentiator for the
early movers
and personalized recommendations have
emerged as one of the strongest
potential drivers
of revenue lift
but as many retailers have discovered
delivering recommendations at scale
can actually be quite complex and time
consuming
on the surface it means for a given
customer in a given context
deciding which item to recommend but
understanding a customer
especially if you don't have a lot of
data about them or if their habits
frequently change can be hard
customers also jump between contexts as
they muld their shopping decisions
and helping them discover new or poorly
cataloged items in a low latency
environment can be
especially challenging
here at google we've developed smart
recommendations
into the magic ingredient that makes our
flagship properties
such a delightful experience google
cloud has packaged together the best of
breed
and deep learning power personalization
and made it available to our customers
through recommendations ai
recommendations ai uses google's latest
machine learning architectures
which dynamically adapt to real-time
user behavior
and changes in variables like assortment
and pricing
it's a fully managed service so there's
no need to pre-process your data
maintain pipelines optimize models or
provision infrastructure to deliver and
scale
we do it all for you automatically
you simply ingest your data retrieve and
display
recommendation results you can get
up and running fast an easy to use
graphical interface can help you
integrate your data configure and serve
recommendations
and monitor system performance and
recommendations can be delivered
at sub 100 millisecond latency to
customers anywhere
in the world irrespective of their
language or location
it's a simple three-step process to make
the most of recommendations ai
first put all your data to work by
codelessly ingesting
it into the recommendations ai using
google tools
you already use next
select your business goals through an
intuitive ui with just a few clicks
and set your models to train and finally
serve recommendations anywhere in the
customer journey across
web mobile or email campaigns
as a bonus we automatically retrain your
models daily
to draw insights from the changing
catalogs user behavior
or shopping trends and incorporate them
into the recommendations being served
there are two parts to the data the
recommendations ai uses to train
personalization models
there's your catalog of items to
recommend that includes item
descriptions
images categories and price
and second there's customer and event
data that is
a history of what users have clicked on
or bought
we've made it seamless for you to bring
your data to recommendations ai
through a plethora of tools you already
use
like google tag manager google analytics
360
google shopping or bigquery and are
continuously working on ways
to eliminate the need for you to write a
single line of code to do this
for example you can now schedule
frequent catalog imports
from google shopping to keep your
catalog of items and recommendations ai
up to date we also monitor the health of
your data feed in real time
so that you can be notified when the
data quality deteriorates
next with just a few clicks in the
recommendations ai console
you can specify the business objectives
you'd like to cater your recommendations
to
first select the recommendation type
that's most relevant for your use case
for example the recommended for you
model is our most personalized model
that many of our customers use in a
placement on their home page
or in email campaigns
most customers complement this with the
others you may like model
through a placement on the product
detail page and the frequently bought
together model
through replacement in the add to cart
pop-up
next specify your objective
it could be maximizing the click-through
rate on the recommendation
the conversion rate or revenue per
session
and finally choose from a plethora of
fine tuning options
that can enable you to do things like
constrain the recommendations
to follow certain business or
merchandising rules or increase the
diversification of items being
recommended our increased likelihood
that higher price items will be
recommended
once you hit the create button in the
console in just a couple of days
your models will be fully trained and
you'll be able to preview the
recommendations they are making
before deploying those recommendations
in production
once your models are ready to serve you
can leverage recommendations ai
anywhere in the customer journey let's
take a look at one customer's journey
as an example a customer begins their
journey on a laptop
browsing the sports apparel category
when recommendations ai
recommends shoes the customer leaves but
comes back to the site on their phone
to view more shoes recommendations ai
steps in again
to recommend sunglasses our customer
adds sunglasses and shoes to their cart
indicating an interest in both items
here
recommendations ai recommend shorts
which the customer clicks on to look at
but ultimately abandons their cart
three days later you can send a
personalized follow-up email to the
customer
with recommended items based on the
customer's clicks and interests
recommendations ai closes the loop
spurring the customer to buy sunglasses
and shorts
both recommended based on the customer's
previous activity across devices
as we can see high quality
recommendations can work
throughout the entire buying process
from initial product discovery on a
laptop
to consideration on a mobile device to
purchasing follow through via email
with recommendations ai delivering
anywhere in the customer journey
also means delivering to any geographic
region
we're globally available and the api
scales to your needs
one of the things i'd like to underscore
is how effective recommendations ai as
deep learning models can be
at uncovering shopper intent
legacy recommendation solutions that
leverage popularity-based
or crowd-based algorithms will usually
anchor
on items or categories but miss the
opportunity to cater
to the individual shopper's journey
altogether
recommendations ai on the other hand is
truly personalized
and looks back at the user's shopper
journey to make recommendations to them
that means if a user has shown an
interest in watches in the past
even when they are looking at a
seemingly unrelated product like address
recommendations ai knows that they have
a high propensity to purchase the watch
and will recommend it to them
and they're always iterating and always
improving
we've made it trivially simple to get
started with recommendations ai
through the console any google cloud
customer
can now enable the recommendations ai
api and train and manage the
recommendation models
with just a few clicks we're constantly
adding
easier ways to ingest your data such as
with the recent ga360 integration
we also now automatically monitor the
quality of your data
and give you the ability to preview
recommendations in the ui
our models can now create faster than
ever before
and are retrained daily to make the most
of the changing patterns in your data
we can handle massive catalogs with tens
of millions of items
in collaboration with some of our
colleagues at google research we're
pushing the boundary of what's possible
for recommendation systems for retail as
an example
some of the work that's come out of that
has made it possible for us to correct
for buyers with popular items
seasonality and leverage item metadata
to make sense of long tail items for
which we don't have much customer click
or purchase data
but ultimately all of this technology
only matters to the extent
that it delivers results as we've been
building and scaling recommendations ai
we've worked with a number of customers
to roll out better recommendations
to 100 of their production e-commerce
traffic
along the way we've been able to prove
our ability
to deliver significant lift on key
business metrics that you care about
as shown in a b test controlled by our
customers
versus their previous recommendation
systems
to talk about some of these results i'd
like to introduce brian
and graham brian is the cto of big
commerce
one of the largest sas e-commerce
platforms in the world and an important
google cloud partner
and graham is the ceo of cubit a leader
in ai led merchandising and personalized
experiences
and an early adopter of recommendations
ai
hello everyone i'm brian dot chief
technology officer at bigcommerce
today i'm going to provide a short
overview of bigcommerce what we do
and why we're really excited about
google recommendations ai
i'll then share a recent case study on
using google recommendations ai with one
of our
merchants and some of our learnings from
that
lastly we'll talk about what comes next
for bigcommerce with
google recommendations ai
first to understand who bigcommerce is
it's important to look at the history of
e-commerce platforms
typically there were two pro options
when it came to e-commerce
open source and sas merchants that
favored full control over the
architecture and build of their site
chose open source merchants that favored
simplicity and security chose sas
that compromise is really no longer
necessary with bigcommerce's open sas
approach
which gives brands the traditional
benefits of multi-tenant sas
usability performance continuous
upgrades
with the flexibility to build and
innovate
over 90 percent of our platform is
exposed via apis
which gives brands the ability to extend
the platform to existing tools and
solutions that they might use
or build completely custom solutions to
complex problems
not only do we provide these
capabilities but we take it a step
further by investing heavily in
integrations with best of breed
solutions and emerging technologies
like ai for example it's because of our
api driven architecture and best of
breed approach that we're here today
talking about google recommendations ai
let's take a closer look
why this integration is so exciting for
us
when we combine google's incredible ai
technology with bigcommerce's powerful
ecommerce platform
incredible things become possible we use
ai technology to enable merchants to
easily
automate parts of their merchandising
strategy
shoppers benefit from being able to more
easily discover products that they'll
love
even when they're browsing through very
large product catalogs
to prove the efficacy of google's ai
functionality we started partnering with
the brand
woolrich and their agency mojo active
we created an a b test where half of the
shoppers on woolrich.com got the
incumbent experience
where the related products section was
powered by a search
algorithm the other half of shoppers got
the same visual design
but we used google's recommendations ai
to determine
which related products would show up our
objective was to increase the
click-through rate on related products
and ultimately
revenue the results are fantastic
with google recommendations ai we
increased the click-through rate by
28 on the related products module
but it delivered a amazing 269
increase in revenue among the cohort of
shoppers engaging with
related product recommendations said
differently
this is the revenue from shoppers
purchasing related products that they
clicked on
we believe this is just the beginning of
what's possible to help shoppers
discover products they love
and to help merchants efficiently and
profitably grow their business
the integration we built starts by
ingesting data into google's ai
platform this included the merchants
product catalog
as well as three months of historical
product page view events for
initial model training we continually
updated google with product catalog data
and product page view data to keep the
machine learning model up to date
and selected the others you may like
model for the product detail placement
once this model was built and trained we
wrapped the google predictions
api into a big commerce api
all aspects of the integration to
google's ai are managed by us within our
gcp account
because woolridge is running their store
in bigcommerce we handled the data
integration
woolridge's agency mojoactive was able
to get woolwich live
easily and quickly with powerful ai
technology
using a very simple bigcommerce api
while the results were fantastic we
discovered a few challenges along the
way
let's take a look at some of the
learnings and where we're headed next
one challenge that surprised us was how
pervasive and sophisticated bots had
become
we found that over 40 percent of site
traffic was generated from bots
and this was a mixture of good bots that
identify themselves and their user agent
data
as well as bad bots that pretended to be
human visitors
filtering out the box became critical to
ensure that we trained the ml model on
human generated data and to ensure we
had accurate reporting on the a b
test we used two methods to improve our
bot filtering
one was to improve our use of user agent
data
and the other was to require javascript
execution to trigger events as older
bots don't tend to support javascript
in regards to the a b testing that we
set up we found this to be
an incredibly valuable way to learn fast
on what is and what isn't working
and ultimately to prove the efficacy of
the solution and the great results we
achieve with roll rich
we are extremely excited about the
results we've seen together with
woolwich
we're now looking to bring google
recommendations ai to more merchants on
the bigcommerce platform
and are expanding the depth and breadth
of our integration with
google recommendations ai if you're
interested in learning more about
creating
personalized shopping experiences on
bigcommerce
please visit us today at bigcommerce.com
google next thanks for spending a few
minutes with me and now with that i'll
turn it over to graham
thank you brian thank you pallav hi
thanks
for all your time my name is graham cook
i'm ceo and founder of cubit
uh excited to be presenting to all of
you today i guess this is the the new
normal
to be uh presenting uh from uh
from my home at these wonderful
conferences like google next
um but i'm really excited to take you
through how
uh the cubic clients are using the
google recommendations uh ai
platform one of the most exciting
technologies we've been working with
in in a long time um so i think it goes
without saying we're reaching uh the
tipping point for digital first commerce
this
this really means that what i'm seeing
across our client base is that there's
just more
and more uh confirmation that
we've got to be operating with the
digital first strategy if you're if
you're a multi-channel retailer
you you've in the past been thinking
about your biggest stores and you've
been thinking about
how to look everything at a store first
model a product first model
well really what we're seeing now it's a
digital first model more and more
businesses are talking about that
how do we work from digital and stores
are just essentially
an arm of digital first commerce um
you know what's driving this is the fact
that it's just gotten massively
accelerated
uh it's been a really hard six months um
i know all of us have really
uh you know found it challenging to be
in trading in these times but but
ultimately what we've seen though
is a is a 10 year leap
in 90 days time and that's a 10-year
leap
in the penetration of e-commerce and
we're now up in that 30 35 plus
of total online spending in e-commerce
and
you know it's incredibly exciting i mean
what we're seeing is pure plays are
doing better than they've ever done
uh multi-channel retailers have uh have
never seen more
sales on ecommerce and really what we're
all of our clients are saying to us is
like how do we keep
up this uh performance how do we keep
the digital channel
performing so well and so what i always
talk to
uh the mark in our customers in the
industry about
is that really as part of this tipping
point digital commerce experiences are
surpassing
the in-store experience and really
that's because the
digital commerce experience is powered
by ai the site
truly knows who you are it's able to
understand you it's able to
guide you through the journey it's
helped helping you find the things and
discover the things you might not have
ever found
and simply walking into a store you
don't get that you don't have that
assistance when you're walking through
the store in the same way because that
store has been built for everybody who
came into the physical location
and the people in that store don't know
you uh deeply uh in many cases and so
you just don't get as great an
experience and i find myself walking
into stores down
and thinking oh this takes so long to
find what i need compared to
how well it works to shop on on many of
our customer
sites so qubit focuses on driving growth
by focusing on relevance for leading
retail businesses within
fashion luxury health and beauty
grocery and really what our customers
are doing is they're using
personalization
and ai led merchandising technology to
focus on driving relevance for their
customer
and by providing more relevant customer
experiences those customers
spend more and come back and become more
loyal
and our customers are able to continue
to be leaders
and continue to advance as as the as the
trend setting brands in the industry so
i'm going to talk about
one of the experiences that our customer
is using
around the ai led uh recommendations
in one of the most notoriously difficult
parts
to do a recommendation model the basket
page
now typically with the um
your your your non one-to-one your crowd
based um models for recommendations
you show a recommendation in the basket
you're probably gonna drive conversion
down significantly because
you're ultimately distracting your
customer as they're ready to check out
with something less relevant potentially
um
nobody's been doing one-to-one in the
basket and so in many cases conversion's
gone down
maybe basket value has gone up to make
up for it but it hasn't been that good
what we've seen with using ai uh google
recommendations ai
in the basket is we've seen a five
percent increase in
revenue per visitor very almost the same
conversion rate
but a big increase in add to baskets and
really what this is the equivalent of
for the first time and you're applying
it to
luxury you're playing to fashion you're
applying it to health and beauty
is you're creating that impulsive at the
checkout
purchase opportunity just like when
you're in an actual physical store
and they've put all the items near the
checkout for you to just pick them up
and put them on the on the till as
you're leaving
so this is the equivalent of impulsive
completely personalized and not
distracting
and it's driving five percent just one
recommendation
model uh carousel doing five percent and
typically what our clients will do is
they will actually
implement uh between five and fifteen
various different personalization ai
powered personalization recommendations
carousels across
their site their app their emails and
the cumulative impact of this is getting
to be 20 25 of uh
additional sales from bringing all these
different strategies together
and really what our clients across the
base as as they're using more
true one-to-one is they're playing that
back to us they're saying
for the first time have we actually seen
what one-to-one recommendations
one-to-one personalization
does for revenue it drives more revenue
than we've ever been able to drive
before
and really what i'm seeing is this leap
from where we've been all these years
we've just been stuck underneath this
impact barrier
and now we're able to break through this
with the real ai
real individualization at scale and it's
thanks to
platforms like google recommendations ai
that we're really able to do this
and what we want to give for our
customers we want to give them the
combination
of the power of the google
recommendations ai but we want to give
them within the
control suite the merchandising control
suite
so that they can control how the
recommendation system will actually work
how they can exclude certain products
include other products the type of model
they want to use
and exactly how it's going to look based
on the different page templates and
strategies
and this is the the relationship between
merchandisers and the ai
that we think allows merchandising teams
to
to really just accelerate and become
more proactive and become the great
merchandisers they are
and and not have to be constantly
working behind the customer they're
working ahead of the customer
with this type of technology and then we
marry that up with other types of
personalization
personalized content other type of
badging scarcity
all within a single easy to use platform
and so under the hood what's actually
happening
is qubit is providing a clean
contextually relevant data feed
in real time that to the google
recommendations ai and so what that
really looks like here on the left
is it's an industry-specific taxonomy so
whether you're in uh
fashion or you're in luxury or health
and beauty or grocery
we have a event-based taxonomy specific
to your industry
and that allows you to feed this deep
contextual
real-time flow of information about
customers about products about
transactions
into the deep learning ai system by the
api
and then all the learning and the
training happens on an individual
customer
at a at an individual shopper at the
brand level
and that's what starts to create this
incredible recommendation system
that then flows back into that
merchandising
and experience workflow tool so the
merchandiser can control how it's going
to look
they can control all the rules and most
importantly they can measure the results
and understand if this type of
personalization is effective at driving
sales or conversions um and helping to
grow the business
and then this is a constant feedback
loop from merchandiser feeding back
context back into the system and that
goes back into
the uh the the recommendations learning
system
and so you know we've been a partner of
google cloud for over five years
and we've never looked back it's it's
most phenomenal cloud platform it's the
most advanced for handling
real-time data systems like this and
it's the only way we could have scaled
what we've built uh for all of our our
hundreds of customers
and really what we're handling here at
peak is 120 000 events per second
we are processing enormous amounts of
information on
really you know on the peak sales days
that we're all coming up to in holiday
um it takes us as well just a second
to take all that real-time information
that's just flowing through it that
hundreds of thousands per second
and put that into the systems that will
will be key to how the data is trained
within the google recommendations
um ai such as bigquery um and typically
our customers are
are sending with a 120 000 different
attributes customer attributes product
attributes into the system
for the for the machine learning to do
its magic
and really um you know i i believe that
deep learning ai
is gonna disrupt retail like we've never
seen it before the next two years
are going to be the biggest shift we've
seen in e-commerce
since the beginning of e-commerce and
it's all happening right now ai is going
to be at the heart of that
and the google cloud recommendations ai
platform
is the way to do this and we'd be really
excited to
uh take you through how to use that with
uh with the cuba platform
so we're in the google cloud marketplace
or alternatively
reach out to your google cloud account
manager or contact us directly at info
at cubit.com we'd love to talk to you
love to hear about your business
i'm going to say thank you very much to
to everybody and thank you
pal evan thank you brian